good morning john so probably you have
heard that for a long time the amount of
energy entering the earth's atmosphere
and the amount leaving the earth's
atmosphere was about the same and that
was good because if those two numbers
are not equal then we're either getting
colder every year or we're getting
hotter every year but now it looks like
there is in fact more energy coming in
than going out and that results in
basically three things first more heat
which is what we call like individual
molecules moving faster which is wild
like when you are hot it is because the
molecules that make up your body are
jiggling more doesn't seem real but it
is second you have more severe weather
which is when a lot of molecules
together move around more and because of
those two you have number three which is
probably the worst of them things are
different that doesn't sound so bad
except that we have built a tremendous
amount of our human infrastructure
designed based on the idea that things
will be roughly the same now as they
were in the past with regards to
rainfall and temperature and stuff like
that when that stuff changes crops might
have dramatically lower yields resulting
in very hungry people people might use
their air conditioners way more than in
the past so entire power grids fail or
forests that grew in areas that once had
shorter dry seasons might burn up in
fires so that's bad and always the first
thing you should ask when something bad
is happening is why is that happening
well you know when you go outside
wearing a black t-shirt you get hotter
faster than if you're wearing a white
t-shirt that's because things only look
black if they absorb all of the visible
light that is hitting them if the light
was not being absorbed it would either
be reflected as white light or as a
mirror or it would be clear which would
be a strange choice for a shirt so if
you're wearing a white shirt the visible
light isn't being absorbed it's being
reflected and that's why you're less hot
absorb reflect or let pass through
that's basically the only three things
that a material can do with light and if
the light is being absorbed that means
the energy of the light hit the molecule
in such a way that it's creating
movement in the molecule the light no
longer exists the energy is now movement
and that movement can be transferred to
other molecules just like a cue ball
hitting a pool ball there are basically
two ways a molecule can heat up and we
just talked about both of them the first
is that a photon travels through space
and then gets absorbed by a molecule and
speeds up that molecule that's heat from
radiation and the second way is that a
particle that's jiggling a lot hits a
particle that's jiggling less and
transfers its heat to that other
molecule when that happens in a solid we
call it conduction when it happens in a
fluid we call it convection so like when
you're in the shade 99 of the heat you
are feeling is from convection it's
molecules in the air running into you
and transferring their heat to you but
when you're in the sun it's a mix of
both the radiation and the convection
which is why it's hotter in the sun now
different molecules absorb different
wavelengths of light like this book
cover is mostly absorbing everything but
yellow and this one is mostly absorbing
everything but red and the red and the
yellow are being reflected back and this
can also happen with gases there can be
green gases and yellow gases and brown
gases but the two molecules of interest
here carbon dioxide and methane they
don't absorb any light in the visible
spectrum which means that they are clear
we can't see them one of the problems
with methane actually if your house is
filling up with it you need to make sure
that you know that that's happening but
you can't see it but at certain infrared
wavelengths which the sun creates a lot
of
they are black and when we put more of
them in the atmosphere our atmosphere is
a little less clear in those wavelengths
and it's a little more black those
molecules absorb photons they start to
move around faster they knock into other
molecules which also start to move
around faster they push on each other
more and more until they have lower
pressure and that hot air starts to rise
cooler denser air rushes in to take its
place and that's weather now those hot
air molecules might remove more moisture
from the soil resulting in more
wildfires they might evaporate more
water from the ocean resulting in bigger
storms we know that this happens we know
how this happens we know why this
happens and we know what the effects are
and we know that the only way to stop it
is for there to be less co2 and methane
in the atmosphere but that is a very
hard thing to do it's very hard and
expensive to remove those things from
the atmosphere it's very hard and very
expensive to replace the agriculture and
energy and transportation infrastructure
that results in the release of those
gases it is not an easy problem to solve
but we have a very strong grip on what
the problem is and i think people can
solve basically any problem if only we
can agree
that it exists john i'll see you on
tuesday